well first of all we have an external
CSS file which we need to construct the
CSS on so if I inline that then that
could save a lot of time same goes for
JavaScript if I inline that then we can
skip the request in fact if I inline
both then that's even better because my
critical path length will be one as soon
as I have the HTML file I have
everything I need
yep that's right those are definitely
good strategies just be careful when you
apply them remember that in lining a lot
of JavaScript and CSS especially when
those resources can be used between
multiple pages can lead to a lot of
overhead right right good point all
right speaking of which I guess I don't
know if this applies to this exact case
but if I knew what was inside the CSS
and JavaScript files then I could also
consider adding a media type to the CSS
or making the script async yep you got
it just a confirm low what would you
look for in these CSS and JavaScript
files well for CSS I'd want to make sure
the styles are actually required to
render the page if they're not being
used I could add an appropriate media
type attribute and unblocked rendering
also it's pretty much the same idea for
JavaScript if the script is not
manipulating or accessing the Dom or CSS
ahhmm then I could add an async
attribute which would unblock Dom
construction yep
that's awesome